- This is the entire conceit
of my business idea, right?
I believe 75 to
80% of sports fans
are in no way woke, right?
Because sports is the
ultimate meritocracy.
If you are the best
at what you do,
you get paid the most and
you are allowed to excel.
That's what should happen
in all of American society.
Instead, we're bringing
identity politics
and cancel culture to sports.
And I think 75,
80% of sports fans
don't want woke sports, right?
They don't want to sit around
and talk about what a
hero Caitlyn Jenner is.
And if you're in that group,
then OutKick is for you.
If you're in the
other 20%, by the way,
there's a knife fight every
day among sports media members
to see who can be the wokest.
They can have their knife fight.
We're gonna serve
the other 75 or 80%
of the sports marketplace.
And I think they're gonna like
what they find at OutKick.
(cerebral music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining
me today is the founder
of outkick.com and truly,
and I mean this truly,
one of the breast men
in all of journalism,
Clay Travis, welcome back
to the "Rubin Report."
- I appreciate you having me.
I'm excited to be back on.
I think the first time I came on
was after that CNN implosion,
explosion ridiculousness
back in 2017, maybe
the fall of 2017,
and a lot of what we
talked about, frankly,
the first time I
came on your show,
has only gotten
worse since then.
And to your credit,
you predicted that
was going to happen.
- (laughs) I take no.
- And you know.
It's just become more chaotic.
- Clay, I take no pride in it,
but before we do anything else,
for those that have not
seen the incredible clip
of you and Brooke
Baldwin, you dared,
dared to say the word boobs on
CNN, and you paid the price.
Paint the picture
for the people.
- So look, I mean,
we know, you know,
that much of TV is
fundamentally artificial.
And so it's easy
to say things like,
"Hey, I'm a first
amendment absolutist,
but the cliche of a
statement like that
sort of deadens it on hearing
because it's so
transparently cliched,
and, frankly, because so
many people who say it
are the exact opposite of
first amendment absolutists.
They don't absolutely believe
in the marketplace of ideas.
And so when I started
saying on my radio show
years and years ago
was the only two things
that have never let me down
are the first amendment
and boobs, right?
Sports talk, radio staple.
- Dangerous.
- A lot of men out there,
a lot of women as well,
agree with that statement.
And so I would kind of say
it as a tongue in cheek way
to advance the first amendment
because that is a little bit
of an outlandish
thing to say, right?
I'm old enough to remember
when the Hugh
Hefners of the world
were considered to be heroes
for their willingness,
the Larry Flints of the world,
to push the of
acceptable speech.
And so in many ways,
you and I overlap here.
I'm much less troubled by
the idea of disagreement
than I am by the
idea of agreement.
Because agreement
is what happens
in totalitarians, governments.
That's not, when everybody
has the same opinion,
it's not because they actually
have the same opinion.
It's because so many
people are afraid
of being able to say
exactly what they think.
So I just kind of
tossed that line out.
I'd done it for years. And
Brooke Baldwin lost her mind.
She was like, "Oh my!"
You know, like
basically, "Oh my God!"
She immediately started
to basically demand
that I give an apology,
and I just leaned into it.
And in so doing, I
think struck a blow
for many people out there
that are just so used to
any time somebody
says I'm offended
that you're just gonna drop
down on your hands and knees
and beg for forgiveness.
And, frankly, she's an
adult, I'm an adult.
What I said wasn't in any
way an offensive comment.
And so why would I
apologize for it?
And she, I think, you
know, began what has become
the ritualized woke
demand for a apology.
And the fact that I
wouldn't do it, I think,
even people who didn't
necessarily agree
with my phrasing
respected the fact that I
wasn't willing to embrace
the ritualized apology, which
has become such a staple
of modern day woke culture.
- Yeah, and subsequently,
flash forward three years,
you're absolutely blowing up,
and OutKick is blowing up,
and you're about to
launch on Locals,
or you just launched
on Locals this morning,
which we're gonna talk
about in just a second.
And Brooke has apparently
retired from CNN.
So these things have a way
of working themselves out.
But before we do some of what
you're launching right now,
do you find it sort of bizarre
that you spend so much time
talking about politics
and all this stuff?
Because partly why
OutKick is successful
is because ESPN went all
in on all of this stuff.
And I mean,
this is what we were talking
about three years ago,
but if anything
it's gotten worse,
and now we're trying to give
people some alternatives.
- No, I think it certainly
has gotten worse.
And I think sports,
I know you're an old
school, 1990s NBA fan,
as many people out there
who watched the Last Dance,
which sort of epitomizes that
era, the Jordan era, MBA were.
And to me, what it represents
is using sports as a fulcrum
upon which to attack basic
American societal values
and create a marketplace where
only one opinion is allowed.
And it came to, I think,
a head regarding people
not even being willing to
go visit the White House,
where somehow if you were
going to the White House,
you were endorsing everything
that the president of the
United States was saying,
all of that was
transparently ridiculous.
And so I think there is a
massive demand out there
for a marketplace of ideas
in the world of sports.
And look, I think
sports and politics
by and large should
be separate arenas
because I think most
people go into sports
to escape the serious
things in life.
You know, guys just want
to kick their feet up,
and girls, and watch a game
instead of having to worry
about everything else
that's going on in politics.
That's why sports
were so popular,
historically, I believe.
But even worse than sports
going political is this idea
that you can only believe that
Colin Kaepernick is a hero
or that Steve Kerr
and Gregg Popovich,
when they were
attacking Donald Trump,
were speaking truth to power
and deserve to be
lionized for that,
or LeBron James or Megan
Rapinoe, it's a one-way street.
If you are a left-wing activist
masquerading in the
world of sports,
you become incredibly,
incredibly praised
by the woke sports media,
which is even more liberal,
and I know this is crazy for
a lot of people to understand,
the sports media is
even more liberal
than the political media is.
Dave, this is going to
be crazy to you, I think,
and I'm still kind
of stunned by it.
Do you know that in the
entire world of sports,
I am the only person
to publicly say
that I was voting
for Donald Trump.
Not one other person
- God, could that be?
with any sort of
substantial audience
in the world of sports
media came out and said,
"Hey, I'm voting
for Donald Trump."
And I laid out exactly
why I was doing that.
And you would be amazed,
or maybe you wouldn't be,
by the 100s of people in
my industry who reached out
and said, "I am doing
the exact same thing.
Thank you for going
public with your vote.
I'm terrified I'll get
canceled, or I will lose my job,
if I say that I am doing
what you are doing."
And that to me is
just an example
of how bereft my own
industry has become
when you consider the
larger arena of sports
and how it intersects
with politics.
- Right, but of
course, the irony here
is that you then,
you saw all this,
you started talking about
it, and then what'd you do?
You didn't just
complain about it.
You started building
your own stuff.
So can you just
talk for a minute
before we get into
the Locals stuff,
about how OutKick is blowing up.
Because we're
watching ESPN crumble.
I mean, I tweet
about it all the time
that I can't watch any
of these things anymore.
I simply, I can't watch them,
but you're actually
building something.
- That's right.
So one of the things
that we're doing
is we're building our
own over-the-top network.
It will include my radio show,
which is on nationwide from
6:00 to 9:00 AM Eastern,
and by the way, is
absolutely exploding.
We have the biggest national
sports talk radio show
in the country for mornings
across the entire United States
which is a pretty good
endorsement of what I am selling
being actually reflected as
being popular among sports fans.
But we're gonna be live,
basically competing
with ESPN programming
through our own OutKick
over-the-top network
from 6:00 AM in the
morning on the East Coast
until 7:00 PM on the East
Coast, which is the time
when there are typically
not games going on.
So 13 hours a day, the plan is
by the time we get to August
to have 13 full hour set up.
By March 15, we will have
seven hours up and running
and basically be
creating our own network.
Now it'll be able to, you'll
be able to consume it,
audio, video, as many
different ways as possible.
You can go to outkick.com.
I'm sure we're gonna
be using your site,
which I give you tremendous
credit for building,
on Locals community
to allow people
to be able to interact with it.
We have set up our own VIP
community where you can sign up
and have exclusive access to
our talent and to our events
to be able to comment, all
of those different things.
We're over 10,000
subscribers for that.
$99 for a year.
We think we're gonna continue
to grow that at a rapid rate.
And look, I believe
in capitalism.
I believe in the marketplace.
And instead of just
standing on the sidelines
and complaining about what
other people are doing,
I want to fight with
them in the marketplace
of ideas and in the
marketplace in general.
And I think we're going to win
because I believe our ideas
in the world of sports
as it intersects with politics
are better than theirs.
I think our people are
smarter, more original,
more authentic and
funnier than theirs.
And I think that that
is what sports fans
are going to respond
to in a big way.
We've already seen
it start to happen.
And I think the future
for OutKick is very bright
as we continue to add more
and more unique voices
to our universe.
- Yeah, and I just love it, man.
Because it's like guys like
us, it's sort of ironic, right?
Like we talk for a living.
So, you know, there's
value in talk.
But one of the things that
I've really shifted on
is like I can't just sit
around and talk all day.
I gotta do stuff.
So that's why I love that,
what everything that you're
building with OutKick.
And now you're gonna
launch on Locals.
So it's outkick.locals.com.
And you're gonna have all
the community features there,
and people can come,
and it will be free of
the big tech overlords
'cause even in the
world of sports,
they're watching you, man.
- No, there's no doubt.
And look, what I believe is
there are a lot of people
who just want to have
honest conversations.
And if you sit there on Twitter
or Facebook or Instagram
or wherever you are thinking
about sharing your opinion,
and you share the
quote-unquote wrong opinion,
you are absolutely lambasted.
And many people may decide,
if you can be tracked down,
that you should be canceled.
And so I think
what we're selling
to many sports fans is water,
and they're in the middle
of walking in the desert,
and they're going
to see us and say,
"Oh, thank God, I can
finally interact with people
who have similar opinions
that I do, and also say
exactly what I think about
the world of sports."
And by the way, it can
just be sports, right?
- Crazy, right?
- Like if you're just
frustrated with the fact
that every single thing that
happens in the world of sports
has to happen through an
identity politics prism.
"Oh, this coach got fired."
"What was his
race? Is that why?"
"Oh, this new player
didn't get the contract
that they thought they were."
"Oh, is that because they're?"
If you're just like, "Man,
I like to watch sports
and talk about the games
that take place on the field
and the actions that
take place there,"
there's, frankly, not
a lot of that anymore.
And so we want to
provide that opportunity
for people as well.
- You know, it's funny,
I was thinking about you
on the way back from
Florida the other day,
'cause I'm on American Airlines
going through their TV app
where you can watch
whatever you want,
and they have like a Black
History Month channel,
or something.
So it's all Black
producers and Black stars.
That's perfectly fine.
You go all the way
to the end of it,
and it's got the Megan Rapinoe
HBO show, and it's like
it just shows you how
stupid intersectionality is.
She's not Black.
If she was Black, that
would be just fine too.
But that they
combined whatever her.
- It's woke
programming, basically,
for lack of a better
way to describe it.
And look, I believe,
and this is the entire conceit
of my business idea, right?
I believe 75 to
80% of sports fans
are in no way woke, right?
Because sports is the
ultimate meritocracy.
If you are the best
at what you do,
you get paid the most and
you are allowed to excel.
That's what should happen
in all of American society.
Instead we're bringing
identity politics
and cancel culture to sports.
And I think 75,
80% of sports fans
don't want woke sports, right?
They don't want to sit around
and talk about what a
hero Caitlyn Jenner is.
And if you're in that group,
then OutKick is for you.
If you're in the
other 20%, by the way,
there's a knife fight every
day among sports media members
to see who can be the wokest.
They can have their knife fight.
We're gonna serve
the other 75 or 80%
of the sports marketplace.
And I think they're gonna like
what they find at OutKick.
- Let me ask you one other
thing before I let you go,
you know, Super Bowl,
a couple of weeks ago,
very few people in
the crowd, you know,
sports are sorta
starting, half starting,
a little bit more in Florida,
maybe Texas, are we ever,
because as you said, I
watched those old NBA games,
and one of the things I'm
starting to notice now
when I watch the games is there
is something truly magical
about being in a
crowd with people,
whether you're the you're
rooting for the home team
or you're rooting
for the road team,
and there is something magical
about being around people,
that shared experience.
You think we're ever
going to get back there,
or have we just done something
to our collective psychology
that half the country
is just gonna be afraid
of ever getting out there
and rooting for teams
and people they
care about, again?
- My hope is, and my belief is
that even the most
woke Corona bro,
as I called them out there,
the people that have been
curled up in the fetal position
in their basements
for nearly a year now,
terrified they're going to
die, are going to eventually,
like groundhogs,
peek their heads up,
look around and realize that
the apocalypse didn't happen.
And that many of us managed
to continue to live
our lives without fear.
You mentioned Florida.
I think Ron DeSantis
has done the best job
of any big state
governor in the country,
despite being the
most criticized.
And I believe States
like Florida and Texas
are going to lead us out
of the sports wilderness
and have full stadiums.
I really believe this,
by around July 4th,
in major league baseball, I'm
advocating for it already.
If you wanna go, look, you
just said you took a flight,
American Airlines, flew
back from Florida to LA,
I'm hopping on a flight
to Mexico tomorrow.
David, if I can sit,
and they told me that there's
no middle seats open, right?
It's completely full flight
because a lot of people
want to go to Mexico
where the weather's perfect,
and I don't blame
them right now,
but if I could sit
on an airplane,
which is an enclosed metal
tube with recirculating air
next to strangers
for hours at a time,
how could I not go sit outside
at a major league baseball
stadium in the sunshine
and have a hot dog and a
beer and kick up my feet
and enjoy a baseball game
surrounded by other people too?
We know COVID doesn't
pass very much outdoors.
If you had to choose
which was safer,
why is airplane
travel commonplace,
you're willing to do it,
I'm willing to do it,
but you can't go sit in a
crowded baseball stadium
and watch games?
But it's one of the big issues
I think so many people have
is kind of the emperor
with no clothes.
We've been sold
artificial bills of good
that have been labeled science,
and they aren't in
any way representative
of what real rational
thought would lead us to make
in terms of choices.
So I think by July
4th, I really do,
that, finally, we're
gonna win this battle.
Schools are gonna
be opening back up,
and I think the
country, ultimately,
I hope we're going to get an
adequate reckoning on this,
but I think as a society,
we have made the worst
decisions since the Vietnam war,
and back then all the
experts were the ones
who told us we had to
go to war in Vietnam.
And over the ensuing
years and decades,
we found out they were
selling a false bill of goods.
I think that's
what's happened to us
with much of the COVID response.
- Yeah.
Well, listen, man, I really,
I'm not just saying this
because you're joining Locals.
I think what you're doing
is the future of
sports journalism.
I think the big boys are
going down, and you're right.
80% of people, they care about
what happens on the field
and on the court, and that's it.
And that's what you're bringing.
So it's outkick.locals.com
to join the Locals community.
And you'll be interacting with
people and all sorts of stuff
over there on outkick.com,
and enjoy Mexico.
Get to have a couple
margaritas in the free.
- And keep up the
good work yourself.
I'm proud of what you're
doing and what you're building
and happy to be a
part of it as well.
Thanks for letting us.
- Right on. Good
seeing you, man.
- Good to see you, as well.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about the media,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our media playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out the full episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.